la conclusion épique du jugement de Dark Knight
Legend of Gotham est l'
événement blu-ray de l'année
la ville a besoin de moi
Oh
Dark Knight Rises sur le pack combo blu-ray
avec le DVD blu-ray et l'ultraviolet
préparez-vous pour une
expérience inoubliable don '  n'ai aucune chance contre
ces gars essaie de m'arrêter comprend plus de
trois heures de bonus explosifs
et saute dans le siège du conducteur pour un
voyage exclusif à l'intérieur de toutes les Batmobiles
souviens-toi où tu te gares télécharge l'
application gratuite Dark Knight Rises et synchronise-la
avec ton blu  -ray disc pour débloquer du contenu exclusif
rien de tel qu'un peu de supériorité aérienne
vous leur avez tout donné mr.  Gagnez
tout oh ouais
le chevalier noir se lève sur le pack combo blu-ray
ou le téléchargement numérique le 28 novembre